all right so I have the privilege today
and I am honored to be joined by the
creator showrunner writer Bruce Miller
of the hand mate so how you new tapers
I'm doing very well thank you
Bruce I saw these first three episodes
like everybody else and it triggered a
lot of thoughts in my head about certain
characters I'm fine I'm I'm hanging in
there but particularly with Serena joy
so Serena joy is a character that we you
know watching this very complicated and
we hated her but now we're getting
towards liking her she's getting her
little Redemption arc here how
challenging is it for you to convince
the audience like to get us on Team
Sarina now uh well I don't try at all
that's the thing I mean you just try to
make her do the things that would make
sense for her and she's not you know
she's a villain in our mais but not in
her mind she has things that she wants
and a lot of them are the same things
that we want so I think the biggest
thing is not to think of her as someone
who were pushing in a direction we I
don't do that I mean we look at the
character and where the character is
going naturally and try to follow let
the character weave the other thing is I
you know I don't know do you believe in
Redemption I mean in real life and I
don't do you remember any time where you
I did a bad thing and then afterwards
you felt like oh I've erased it and I
just don't think it's a thing I don't
believe in Redemption arcs I mean I
don't think unless someone's gonna come
down and give you a star in your head
and say you're now redeemed III think
you know they're all just part of the
ebb and flow of people doing things they
think are morally right and things that
are morally wrong and in between I you
know so Serena I don't think has a
Redemption arc this season she has a
motherhood arc okay
that clears up a lot of things and that
Wow that's a lot to take in and it feels
like almost you're saying to like it
isn't like when you're going out and
writing a story like this it isn't so
black and white there is so much grey in
here and even the characters we see and
it's not just you know good versus evil
would you say all the time where is it
oh I don't think it's you know I mean
it's not good versus evil one of the
things you know the people in the show
who seemed to be villains have a
worldview and have built that they think
this is necessary and it's and it's
sure to understand in that world I mean
imagine what things would be like here
if in five years the the birth rate
dropped 98 percent things would change a
lot and what you thought was extreme
behavior might change and what you are
willing to do might change and so I
think that what's what Yvonne and Joe
finds and and out do so well is they
play real people and they show you the
how those people are thinking and a lot
of the things that these characters are
doing things they don't want to do they
feel like are necessary to do and so III
I don't think of the show as good and
evil and and because you know look at
the things that June's character has to
do you know and especially this season
when she's trying to actively resist and
trying to be you know trying to be a
hero and it's not as easy as it is on TV
so it's interesting you say that about
June being a hero because I thought from
these especially the premiere it really
painted like Oh June is a hero in a
sense especially making the decision
that was controversial at the finale
last season to stay or not but I thought
it was a perfect choice and I thought
the premiere to me was selling know this
this is the way the show should have
went and this is what really paints her
as that hero because it's like oh she's
not forgetting about her other kid while
she's technically I believe making the
smart choice and giving the other kid to
Emily to go to Canada because I think
that's still the best odds I have a
better life so I think the premiere kind
of painted that perfectly did you feel
when you were planning season three that
you had to address in a way those people
that were like hit or miss about her
staying yes but more the ones in house
like me I mean we had a very long
discussion about what she was going to
do you know we we as writers we try to
follow the story and follow the
characters and if June got on that truck
and left we would have had a season next
season and that would have been she
would have been in Canada we we were
averse to that but I couldn't for the
life of me believe that she would get on
the truck and leave her child behind I
have three children and there's only two
that I would leave behind one of them I
would stay for and and otherwise if she
stayed I couldn't believe she didn't get
on the truck so it was one
those things were I don't think either
decision would have people would have
been happy with but I I know that I was
as frustrated with June as the audience
was that she didn't make the other
choice but I think I don't know what her
life would have been like leaving her
child I don't know that she would have
been a husk of a human being she's to
leave your daughter behind not knowing
where she is or if she even if she's
safe with a family you know what her
family is like I don't think I'd be able
to do that so that's interesting because
we see also June sees her daughter in
gilead in this season and early on and I
just feel like there's a timer on her in
the sense of when is it gonna become
where she's gonna just lose her child to
this other woman and it's hinted at with
the dialogue and her saying like you
know you're just gonna confuse her now
and do you think there's a part of June
that's like fighting against that and
there's maybe a little denial they're
like wait a minute I know I'm trying to
say every but when is it like I'm a
stranger and I'm interfering with her
new life no that's exactly the story and
I think that what what we were trying
there's a scene in the first episode
that that is between June and someone
connected to I don't know when you're
gonna put this on
but someone connected to her daughter
and I really wanted to it was a very
difficult scene to write because I
wanted to make sure that woman had a
point of view that made sense that she
wasn't just evil that you know from her
point of view this was someone whose
mother was unfit she had married a man
who was already married as far as they
were concerned which means she had a
baby out of wedlock she was not married
and they were certainly not married in a
church as far we've seen so you know and
it was the second marriage and she's not
a woman of faith so as far as she's
concerned this and that happens in our
society there are different rules from
it what makes you unfit but they take
babies away from unfit people all the
time and so that it's not a crazy
dynamic and now I forgotten your
question no yeah you answer it so don't
I forgot it too I was just listening I
was enjoying um but
talking about complicated characters we
were talking about before like Serena
Joy I think the most complicated in my
eyes now is commander Lawrence
I'm it's it's very hard to read my
obviously that's on purpose and they
even have lines referencing that but I'm
wondering when we first met him in
season 2 there was already some
confusion the fan base like is he
serious when he's saying hey if you keep
talking to that Martha or is he joking
and he's helping Emily but is he
trustworthy right so how worried are you
when you introduce a character like Oh
what do we not wanna paint him like do
you think of that consciously like that
it could screw up how he appears maybe
in season 3 or beyond like introduction
to somebody like him especially well
certainly when you introduce the
character it's a big discussion about
how you're gonna do it but because first
impressions go a long way you know you
seem lovely and so you know a thinks
things like that you know they matter so
when you introduce this character you
really have to say people are gonna have
a sense of him right off the bat is that
since gonna be borne out or is it going
to be muddled in this case I think it's
probably muddled it's you know that some
of the things you thought right off the
bat were true he seems to be a very
smart guy he's also a weird guy you know
and he's more he kind of likes to be
entertained you know he kind of looks at
her like oh you seem to be interesting I
like something interesting in my house
and so I think that when we introduced
him what I mean we were lucky we had
Bradley who's astonishing and we could
really write a character that was a
mercurial impossible to put your finger
on and and not trying to be mercurial
he's not trying to like he doesn't he's
not teasing Jun what he's trying to do
you know he's just being himself he just
doesn't really have any sense of how
that sounds to other people so that was
our big big thing is that you know he's
someone who has you know who understands
humanity but humans are a little
difficult yeah I that sounds about right
and uh yeah it's interesting and I'm now
I'm just coming to my head action and
thinking about the game of Thrones that
just ended right and you know the
showrunners of that show got a lot of
heat of how it ended yeah a lot and
everyone is different pains on it but
I'm wondering as a showrunner yourself
do you see that and worry like oh how am
I gonna do you have like a vision like
how this is
all gonna and Eve are you worried about
getting into a trap or something could
be rushed or do you think of that now
does that make you like scared that like
whether you like to Game of Thrones or
not it's finale that they got a lot of
heat and does that like something you
like toss and turn about I hope that
doesn't happen to me like I don't know I
feel like I'd be doing that yeah it was
scary because showrunners have gotten a
lot more accessible and in the last five
years you know just with Twitter and
they've been their voices are a little
louder and people know people know that
I'm making a show which you know years
ago I mean I don't think my family knows
what a showrunner does I mean my my
extended family you know I have to
explain it to them all the time so I
don't really get nervous because I've
been doing this a long time and one of
the things about TV is that you always
think you have to continue the story so
a lot of what you do is at the end of a
season you write a finale and then what
I try to do is wow I hope there's some
smart writers who come along next year
to fix this and you just completely
forget that it's you and so what you try
to do is just build a solid character
solid stories and then those things are
the best things to move into the next
realm I think if you try to push your
character the audience feels that now
the audience has been watching you know
my children have watch much more
narrative than I did at their age
including you know they watch a hundred
stories they you know little things on
YouTube Instagram and they're always
watching narrative they know what the
hell's gonna happen they know how a
dramatic narrative is put together so
you can't you know keep that stuff in
mind or you know my 14 year olds ago
okay well that's the bad guy I knew that
was the bad guy just from the shot from
the angle from the music so you really
have to be a lot more grounded not to
make them unpredictable but not to make
them surprisingly unpredictable but I
think when our characters do something
you want to feel that makes sense it's
perfectly inevitable and they didn't see
you coming right so okay I like that now
you mentioned your kids do they want to
be now seeing what daddy does do they
want to be showing us they want to be
writers actresses even I don't know I
think writing is a weird thing to do for
a living just because you know there's a
you know an aspect to it that is slow
and thoughtful and
you know it take them works on its own
schedule on television doesn't work on
its own schedule television is very very
schedule driven so you know you have to
learn to write well fast so I don't know
I I think seeing what what if show run
show runners a difficult job I mean it's
wonderful to have it but it's 24/7 and
exhausting and I think them seeing what
it does to you I don't know whether they
would be so so keen but they're all very
interested in writing at all very
interested in Phil but I don't think any
of them would be actors okay okay that
was I feel like that's what they all say
and then eventually they're gonna just
bullet now when you're you see Margaret
out what's coming out with a sequel so
The Handmaid's Tale in the fall are you
told by her what's coming are you trying
to separate the show from where maybe
the books are going or is there a long
end game that connects them both I don't
know anything but is there conversations
like that with Margaret
there's absolutely conversations like
that with Margaret I was you know in the
unbelievable bizarre and viewable
position of having Margaret chitchat
with me about the story as she was
working on it which is just unfathomable
to me so I think that you know my show
is always a companion piece to
Margaret's work it's not it doesn't
supersede it what do you hope is at the
end when this shows done you know you
have a nice DVD set to put on the shelf
next to the book and the sequel to the
book so you know more than discussing
where we're gonna go I listen to her
about where she's going to go and I
follow so but in terms of an end game we
I very much have kind of a sense of
where the story is going but I think the
important thing is something you
mentioned earlier which is the hardest
thing is not to rush and this is a show
where we're it being taking your time
because things are kind of complicated
is my favorite thing about it you know
we've got we're lucky enough to have
those great actors and Lizzie has that
face and so you know it I think it would
be a tragedy to kind of move past things
that are complicated and interesting
without exploring that interesting so
before we wrap I had to ask this I'm a
huge fan of Elisabeth Reiser I'm
wondering if she was casting this for me
watching haunting of Hill House have you
seen the show what where does where does
that come and when do we expect in the
season to see her because I'm after even
three Episode I haven't seen her and I'm
dying to see what her pardoned them all
this is I'm trying to remember what
episode she appears in and I don't
remember but it's it's it's I think it's
half about halfway through the season
and no I've just always been a fan and
you know we had a couple of roles before
but she's just a remarkable actress and
you know when you watch someone's career
what I always look for is not kind of
individual performances but the range
that like you see someone plates like
Elisabeth Moss you know you see her play
offered and then she's in her smell and
then she's in us you know and she's so
different such a community so it's that
range that Elizabeth had that was really
attractive and everything I think
everything she's in and everything she
does this was she's super interesting in
so I was very happy to to rehab she was
available that's awesome my last
question for you coming off of the big
reveal we had at the end of episode 3
because this will be airing after
episode 3
Serena joy and Joon kind of have their
little moment where they're teaming up
now get on the same page is this gonna
be a catalyst of hope now we're getting
is would you say viewers can expect
maybe season 3 to have more Hope than
season 1 and 2 hat or do you think we're
kind of gonna be same ball field here
well I think June is definitely much
more active and she is trying to change
things and so there's plenty more
victories for June and and I think some
incredible victories but I think more of
it is about the character of June and
what what does a hero really look like
in the real world and what that means
for June is stubbornness and tenacity
more than anything else so you know I've
heard a lot of people say you know you
know if people are just there to mean to
to June and guilty at I mean it's it's
horrible that there's so many did you do
it yet but we
she's that's what she's fighting against
and they're not gonna stop being mean to
her and I think that if June's gonna be
a real hero she has to get knocked down
and pick herself up she has to keep
driving she has to make mistakes she has
to do all those things because then
because I don't know about you but if
someone said to me okay you're a rebel
rebel I wouldn't have any idea what to
do she's learning she's figuring out
it's not as easy as it is on television
people die you have to convince people
to do things that are not you have to
manipulate people you have to do all
these things and that's the arc that
she's going through is she's becoming a
rebel reader but that is not as easy and
clean as you think and also I you know I
I think we've been sold a bill of goods
that you know that you can be a hero by
summoning your super powers and I think
you know June when she's knocked down
she wishes she has super powers and she
gets up anyway yeah totally I can see
it's got that Avengers feel now so she's
three to Joe in the big do you have a
personal favorite character of yours oh
you know I know but I mean a busy of the
character of June I'm so married to at
this point and and wizzy and I have
grown so close over the years I mean I
feel like you know I love you love all
your characters and you try to find
things that you love in them then maybe
they don't love in themselves and all
that stuff but you know June is is she's
she's the handmaid in the Hammond it's
down and it's hard not to love her yeah
personal favorite episode uh you know I
like some of the weirder ones I think
the one where she gave birth was
probably my favorite episode because it
was so it was just Lizzie all alone and
I remember the night we filmed her
giving birth you know and here's a it's
a room in a house with a fire and no
other light and she's not wearing
anything and she was in there for two or
three days doing this and I didn't go in
there it was her the director who was a
woman and the DP who was a woman in that
room for two days and that it was and
and what is he you know doesn't have
children of Rhodes you got to talk to
people to find out what that was like
and that was one of the more astonishing
things I've ever I've ever seen
it was beautiful but also and also it
really made me feel what June was
feeling the joy and the pain and all
those kind of things I just thought it
was so interesting that here's one of
the nice things about Gilead is that
when you give birth you're surrounded by
people who love Leo by your hand mades
and your friends and over the pantheon
and even though it's horrible it's
supportive she's alone so even in Gilead
she ends up giving birth alone it's
amazing and it just shows again just
showing how amazing an actress she is to
be able to pull that off without even
having experienced that before is
unbelievable Bruce thank you so much for
joining me today I really appreciate it
everyone please make sure just keep
watching hey Misa on Hulu drops on
Wednesdays check out my reviews of the
show and I also interviewed Nina kiriwe
plays almonds so check that out as well
she's the best uh-huh and she has great
things to say about you she said I told
her I was interviewing when she said he
is the greatest guy in the world so she
dyes her back first don't worry about
that thank you for joining me and stay
tuned for more